One piece of evidence that I love,
I think it's so well,
there's a couple.
One I would derive from friends to wall
who's a famous primatologist and he
studied,
he studied the prototype morality that
emerges in chimpanzees and it's very
much rest nested in their dominant
structures,
you know,
because you could think of morality in
some sense as the understanding of the
rules by which the dominance hierarchy
operates.
Right.
And so you could say,
well,
the biggest,
ugliest,
meanest chimp and the male dominance
hierarchies in chimps seemed to be the
predominant ones.
Although the females also have a
dominance hierarchy in it.
It's not quite so clear in Bonobos,
which seemed to be more female
dominated.
But in any case,
I'm the champ.
Primary chimp dominant structure is male
and you could think,
well,
it's like the.